en eeuu la inflación está en su punto
más alto en 40 años las acciones a la
baja y las tasas de interés al alza
haciendo que los préstamos sean mucho
más costosos adicionalmente la economía
se contrajo en los primeros tres meses
de este año 2022 ante toda esta
situación la pregunta que muchos se
hacen es si eeuu corre entonces el
riesgo de sufrir otra recesión económica
y si esta situación va a mejorar en un
futuro cercano a pesar de la inflación
el mercado laboral se ha venido
recuperando y aunque varias empresas han
empezado a sentir que están sobre
contratando de cara a una posible
recesión pues vamos a solucionar todo
esto ya ver qué va a pasar entonces con
este primero invitado al día el están en
la calle doctor en economía economista
profesor de ie business school gracias
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france24 àngel también nos
acompaña en nuestra estudio en esta mesa
de trabajo nuestra periodista de
economía daniel hablando con daniela
bienvenida muy buen día feliz mañana
lunes feliz mañana para ustedes raúl
también para nuestro invitado y pues yo
quisiera que paramos de una vez grano
porque el temor hoy en día de todos los
mercados no solamente de eeuu sino
también de todo el mundo es que entremos
en una nueva recesión empezando por eeuu
ya hubo un decrecimiento de la economía
en el primer trimestre en el segundo
trimestre que acaba de cerrar que
podemos esperar
bueno yo creo que el segundo trimestre
la evolución va a ser muy similar la
estimación de la reserva federal de
atlanta
muestra que el producto interior bruto
de eeuu pues como mucho pues se
recuperará un poquito pero claramente lo
que estamos viviendo es la resaca de los
estímulos del año 2020 2021 un exceso
absolutamente espectacular de gasto
público aumento de la masa monetaria y
con ello obviamente pues ahora digamos
el efecto búmeran el efecto resaca y no
solamente le está ocurriendo eeuu en la
eurozona el riesgo de recesión también
es muy elevado y yo diría que en la
mayoría de las economías desarrolladas
precisamente porque claro simplemente el
efecto del aumento masivo del gasto
público el producto interior bruto de
2020 y 2021 y el aumento de las
importaciones por el aumento del coste
de la energía claramente van a tener
pues ahora un efecto negativo claro eso
también con la guerra democrática va a
ser otro tema pero antes de entrar en
eso danielle yo le quería preguntar cómo
podemos explicar digamos que podríamos
estar ad portas de una recesión
económica no sólo en eeuu sino también
como lo decías de una manera en general
cuando la gente digamos sobre todo en
ese país norteamericano está gastando
digamos de una manera pues excesiva el
mercado laboral sigue en auge también
con esta sobre contratación del personal
de las empresas y que también el
desempleo pues bajó ya digamos a unos
niveles pre pandémicos
bueno yo creo que es muy interesante
entender también ese efecto euforia
antes de una recesión ya ocurrió en el
año 2007 antes de la crisis de 2008 ojo
que una recesión una crisis no es lo
mismo las recesiones dos trimestres de
caída del producto interior bruto y
varios sectores pueden mantenerse con
una actividad relativamente sólida en un
entorno de recesión recordemos porque
hay recesión es decir en eeuu ha habido
un trimestre en el que ha bajado el
gasto público pero no porque haya una
recesión sino porque aumentó masivamente
el año anterior y por lo tanto el efecto
comparación muestra un dato negativo las
importaciones de energía son mayores que
las exportaciones pero las exportaciones
están creciendo es decir que todavía la
economía el sector privado está
funcionando bien pero no podemos olvidar
que en esos positivos datos de empleo en
cuestionable mente no podemos olvidar
que x la tasa de participación laboral y
el ratio de empleo sobre población están
todavía por debajo de los niveles de
febrero de 2020 antes de la pandemia por
lo tanto yo creo que simplemente es que
hemos vivido una época de 2020 2021 en
la que ese aumento masivo de la masa
monetaria por parte de la reserva
federal y con ello el aumento también
del gasto público para dar cheques a las
familias para hacer un plan de estímulo
etcétera pues ahora está generando ese
efecto resaca como le llamo yo el señor
daniel también hay un fenómeno laboral y
es que cuando él a principios de este
año las empresas estaban desesperadas
por encontrar personal ahora están
reduciendo un poco esa contratación pues
con miras a que haya una posible
recesión y pero al mismo tiempo por cada
dos por cada desempleado hay dos ofertas
de empleo cómo explicar todo este
fenómeno ahora volar que se está dando
en eeuu
bueno tenemos que explicarlo por dos
lados por un lado ha habido una enorme
cantidad de población en eeuu que ha
salido de la fuerza laboral de acuerdo y
por lo tanto cuando se recupera la
economía y empiezan a aparecer
oportunidades de contratar muchos
trabajadores no están disponibles
adicionalmente hay una enorme diferencia
entre sectores a los sectores en los que
hay una tensión en la
demanda de empleo que por otro lado
pues no encuentra oferta y sin embargo
hay otros en los que la oferta excede
cómo acaba usted de comentar la oferta
pues hay más ofertas de empleo
disponible entonces esto suena digamos
complicado de entender pero lo que está
mostrando es que hay sectores que han
salido mucho más rápido de la pandemia
con mucha mayor fortaleza y otros que no
y que además hay un efecto de
desplazamiento de fuerza laboral
muchos trabajadores que no están
acudiendo a esas ofertas de trabajo
porque porque todavía mantienen cierto
ahorro de cuando se dieron toda esa
cantidad de cheques por parte del
gobierno esos estímulos monetarios de
2020 y también porque los costes de pues
lakers guardería de gasolina cetera
etcétera a muchas personas no les sale
con económicamente interesante ir a un
puesto de trabajo cuando los costes han
aumentado tan